I don't think he had any intention of
trying to enter the Tory leadership
contest Donald Trump is simply a man who
likes to speak his mind he can't really
help himself it's part of his brand he
shoots from the hip he tells it like it
is and also quite frankly I'm not sure
he really cares either who he really
offends it was quite obvious to us that
there were quite a few people who didn't
wanted to say this sort of thing when we
left the Oval Office we were told by his
press people that clearly he wasn't
endorsing any candidate he couldn't
write it up that way we thought we'd let
the quote speak to themselves we knew
Donald Trump is a fan of Boris Johnson
we could have guessed he might have
liked Jeremy Hunt could have guessed he
didn't like Michael go very much if he'd
heard what he said about Iran but I
don't think any of this quite frankly is
gonna move the barometer the Tories are
gonna elect someone who they think and
so breaks it and get them reelected
Donald Trump almost only won't play a
very big part in that the idea that he's
gonna get Street protests against him I
think he's almost in complete denial
about he told me it wasn't true he said
people loved him and I think we'll also
have to wait to see what happens on
Monday who's right about that